Vivek Bald: Welcome back to
everyone. And welcome to those
of you who have joined us before
the afternoon session. And we
are going to go I think straight
into the next presentation,
which is presentation by Andrea
Kim. The title of Andrea's
presentation is the myth of post
racial avatars, anime girls, and
the shoujo ghost, and the cyber
shaman in virtual worlds. And
I'm gonna pass it over to Fox to
introduce Andrea.
Fox Harrell: Great, I'm really
pleased to have the chance to
introduce Andrea, because I
think it's not only a
fascinating but important pieces
so that she is completing and
representing on today. So it's
important for a number of
different reasons, I think. One
is the fact of that many people
formerly saw virtuality as a
nice to have, but as evidenced
by this meeting here today, it
seems to have become a must have
in so many parts of our world
today. But that also means
there's a convergence of what
these platforms impose upon us
and, and how they allow us to
mediate our identities and
selves in virtual spaces. And
some of the ways that these that
these spaces do so are through
pre constructed characters
through the kind of environments
through the logics that include
logic, logics of colonialism,
military industrial complex, and
much more than that, you know,
that again mediate how we
present ourselves in these
spaces. So this, this
convergence of the ways that
virtuality has become, must
have, along with the the kind of
commercial spaces and the ways
that they impose constraints
upon us. And then, sadly, also
have to say, this particular
moment, and the types of
violence and prejudice that
exist, including the recent
terroristic attacks against
Asian people, and Asian women in
particular, all come together in
unfortunate ways, but ways that
we also have possibility to
revise and do better. So the
reason I said that Andrea's work
is important is because it calls
attention to this convergence to
the impacts and the nature of
it, but also points towards a
way out of this and towards a
way that people's identities can
be a positive resource for the
future and a positive resource
towards moving beyond violence
and prejudice and towards a
place of creative and empowering
self expression for the social
good. So I'll leave it at that,
you know, but I hope that you
will join me in welcoming Andrea
Kim to present on her thesis
work.
Andrea Kim: Thank you. So Hello,
my name is Andrea Kim, and I'd
like to introduce my master's
thesis, The Myth of Post-Racial
Avatars: 'Anime Girls,' the
Shōjo Ghost, and the Cybershaman
in Virtual Worlds. So the
avatarized anime girl can reveal
much about how cultural
phantasms are actively produced
in virtual worlds, not only for
the users but through the
computational system itself.
phantasms describe how our mind
body complex blends sensory
input, such as the anime avatar
that reflects aspects of a
particular worldview, such as
that of such that shōjo girls
are innocent, cute feminized
objects of affection. phantasms
are only semi visible and need
to be revealed. Otherwise,
they're taken for granted.
They're also mysterious people
cannot pin down precisely how
they came to be possessed by a
particular phantasm. This is a
concept put forth by Professor
Harell, who is an advisor to
this thesis. Also with Dr.
Manduhai Buyandelger on the
committee. Thank you both for
your thoughtful guidance for
this research.
Well the topic of my research I
examined the cultural production
of anime girl avatars in VRChat
to understand sociotechnical
relations to virtual worlds
making? specifically I focused
on world making in the social VR
platform VRChat. worlds making
is a term I draw from
anthropologist and playwright
Dorinne Kondo who uses the term
to describe how structures of
power, labor processes and
performances of subjectivity are
linked into theater industry,
thinking about making an
unmaking of racial
constructions. For instance, in
my study, I aim to deconstruct
cultural biases embedded in
social VR and explore the
potential of social VR for
digital performance. I asked how
does social VR mediate embodied
experience and what
opportunities does it present
for reorienting our approaches
to virtuality four methods, I
employ the phantasmal media
approach which encompasses an
analytic method and a design
practice, which are both within
the scope of this study. I also
used ethnographic methods
informed by critical theory to
immerse audiences into social VR
to consider broader implications
beyond the medium. I think it's
important to note here that also
the studies focused on English
speaking users in VRChat who are
using the referencing shōjo as
anime girls as well. As for
findings, I discover that
cultural biases are embedded
into the social VR media
ecosystems at a socio technical
level, meaning that the
materiality of digital spaces
acts upon users and their
behaviors. First, social VR
embodies new media logics that
produce and mask phantasms that
affect social relations. Second,
aesthetic and data structures of
MMD based avatars are
intertwined with values that
reproduce tropes about Asian
femininity, and reduced bodies,
digital physical, femme, Asian
or otherwise, as manipulable
objects of the colonial male
gaze. In this thesis, I argue
that being on ma is not a post
racial conceit but one built
from a situated cultural
imaginary, that erases the
bodies of Asian girls and women
in its construction of virtual
personhood. A key insight
emerges here, we need more
intersectional feminists design
of digital avatars that make
apparent the racial and gendered
power dynamics in virtual worlds
making, but also we see an
opportunity. Social VR offers
new possibilities for identity
play and trans cultural
learning. When engaged with a
multidisciplinary practice
grounded in values of care. I
apply these findings to a design
component for which I am
developing a working concept of
cyber shoe monic performance to
draw from practices rooted in
cultural memory to inform
virtual world making. This led
to the design of a VR work
called a place of care, which
responds to our contemporary
moment in regards to violence
against Asian women. So a place
of care on March 16. a month ago
on this day, eight people were
killed in a mass shooting in
Atlanta, six Asian, seven women,
as a Korean American researching
representations of Asian
femininity. incidents like this
remind me of the deep rooted
cultural violence affected upon
migrants, immigrants and Asian
woman in America. This writing
by Yin Q, a labor activist,
articulates my shared sentiment
as we write massage parlors,
where people are given touch,
intimacy, where you lay your
head down to sink into yourself,
where a massage worker cares for
your body and tries to heal it
inside a gun into a place of
care. Not a religious space, but
certainly a sacred space where
you feel human and humbled. So a
place of care invites
participants into a massage room
to engage with their affective
relations to that space. It
invites users to address the
fear stigma or misperceptions
learned from mainstream society
about bodywork, especially from
agents and immigrants,
participants can experience the
massage room as a place of
healing and memory of the last
loss for this senseless
violence. In this work, I draw
from popular storytelling
practices that center voices in
the margins. So social Europe
back to social VR, and why now,
here we have some popular social
VR platforms alt space, Mozilla
hubs, Facebook Horizon, we see
social networking like Facebook
converging with VR as a consumer
product as we see with these
images of headsets. Throughout
my research in social VR for the
past year, I've been to film
festivals, experimental theater
shows, pole dancing and club
venues, a course at Harvard, and
many other live events, spaces,
finding solutions to programming
halted from the pandemic. And
2020 has definitely been a big
year of experimentation in
social VR. And the platform in
which I conducted my study is
VRChat. Your chat additionally
to creating an attending a
variety of events, users can
build their own avatars and
virtual worlds in unity and
import them into VRChat. They
can build studios or livestream
a talk show go world have
popping, and there is a robust
community of makers and
freelance artists.
Ugandan knuckles which is a
viral meme and video that cause
VRChat's popularity to spike in
2018, is a phenomenon that
demonstrates the performance of
media culture in advertised
form, but also in the way that
it reproduces racist behaviors.
You gotta knuckles remix is a
character from the sonic
franchise with a mean into a 3d
avatar that users can use
usually to troll people with
racist skit about African
people. Hatsune Miku is also
popular. A virtual idol with a
huge global fan, fan base, and
furries in the furry fandom also
use VRChat to meet up with
friends talking, taking their
media and furry embodiment
practices into avatars forms. So
not only our characters perform
through avatars in VRChat, but
also through various media
products. The theoretical
underpinnings Digital Media
Studies, cultural studies and
feminist selection theories can
offer various angles from which
to consider mediation and social
VR. So Digital Media Studies
gives us insight into the
interface between VR and human
cognition, media convergence and
the cultural logics guiding
emergent in media. Cultural
Studies presents techno
Orientalism coined by Morley and
Robbins and [...] from Edward
Said to just refer to discourses
emerging after world war two
responding to rapid economic
developments in Japan, and
shifts in global power. techno
Orientalism does reverse refers
to the idea of the Orient that
typecast Asians as less human
components of techno virtual
worlds to conquer techno
Orientalism assigns
technological and thus inhuman
characteristics to Asian people,
and is an expression of desire
to reify Global imperialism
through technology. And so in
this image, we see some
cyberpunk imagery that
predominates popular notions of
futurity. And finally, I draw
from feminist and subaltern
theories that emphasize situated
and relational knowledges.
feminist and self some alternate
practices bring worlds into
views while critically
interrogating the mode of
viewing concepts like auto
ethics or onto aesthetics onto
epistemologies refer to the
inextricable link between being
and knowing, and unlike
relational ontologies, they
require us to consider the at
those apparatuses of knowing in
terms of method I entered into
the spirit of situated knowledge
is I employed auto ethnography.
But my auto ethnographic
experience was marked by
disorientation and not the
deconstruction of self as much
as the construction of self. So
I went on and off your chat over
the course of 10 months, and
interviewed with 10 VRChat
community leaders and world
makers, interviews focused on
the makers hosts and content
creators and such. From the
phantasmal media approach, I
applaud two approaches to
challenge negatively. bias to
phantasms one is to reveal
phantasms by showing them from
multiple worldviews, such as the
assumptions in each are such
that the assumptions within each
become clear. And secondly,
creating empowering phantasms
that through developing a design
practice. phantasms are
cognitive terms that call
attention to how phenomena are
only semi visual describing how
blending sensory input and a
concept rooted in a particular
worldview produces a new idea.
So the phantasms of others are
often seen only partially seen
only partially knowable. This
mysteriousness is used often to
support justifications or
explanations of behaviors, such
as Asian woman, or submissive
because they are all from a
patriarchal culture. So with
phantasmal media in mind, I
analyzed the MMD 3d model as a
data structure from which the
anime girl aesthetic came to be
and the systems in which they're
intertwined. So really quickly,
for those of you unfamiliar with
social VR, or VRChat, here are
some of its affordances. With
virtual reality, we've got
single view perspective,
perceptual realism, meaning that
the representations On screen
are like,
represent our replicating
perception outside of VR. And
there's a sense of heightened
presence as well. Social VR is
digitally, you have digitally
embodied social presence through
voice chat or graphical avatars,
you're spatially close to to
others. And there's the element
of network community
connectivity. And so when you
look in the mirror, in terms of
the effect or the techno
sensorial relation between our
bodies and our avatars, studies
have shown that when you look at
the mirror and have a moment of
self recognition, the pairing of
the gestural movements and the
visual continuity of your avatar
increases a sense of embodiment
and identification with that
avatar figure. Now, these
affordances of heightened
presence also come with some
risks. Issues of harassment
predominate, the early years of
social VR and there have been
reports that come out that
articulate the PTS how PTSD can
be triggered through social VR.
And so we have here a
performance by Michelle Cortez,
who is a designer for Facebook
social VR platform to design it
in a more sensitive way that
keeps account of bodily autonomy
and prevents issues of serious
harassment. And so in this
performance piece, she spends
four hours to question different
like avatar, anime style avatars
to like in an investigative way,
and to see what they have to
say. her. Her performance
focuses more on the user agency
side of the question of wanting
to give face to or give voice to
the men behind the image. And
her findings from this was that
they were predominantly had had
performances of heteronormative
masculinity and also instances
of sincere gender play. So my
first finding is that social VR
embodies new media logics that
produce ambiguous socio
technical links between the
Avatar and virtual world. The
main point here is to think
about how the new media logics
of immediacy and hyper
immediacy, our intention, social
VR embodies this paradox in a
way that masks how it operates.
The bodily effect of immersion
from VR aims to erase the medium
through realism. While this
avatars in VR platform itself
makes it known that it's VRChat,
virtual reality, or the
metaverse as the self, people
self reflexively call the VRChat
world, it is embodied in a way
that the Avatar and socio
technical system are linked at
an inherent level. And so these
are kind of three examples that
show that inherent link between
the Avatar and socio technical
system. One is that blocking
users show that despite the
guise of immediacy of a shared
space, not all users see or hear
the same things you can block
users or change the settings.
And the reality is that not
everyone is seeing the same
thing, even if they're together.
Secondly, the avatar performance
ranking exemplifies how it's a
it's a metric in which not just
the complex avatars are not
necessarily the better ones, but
avatars are kind of valued by
how it democratizes
communication with the bandwidth
with everyone else in the room.
And another example is seen in
avatar worlds or the
proliferation and predominance
of the anime girl aesthetic
scene in VRChat, it really
provokes the question of why,
and is, you know, asking people
this question, often get a
response at Oh, it's the easiest
style of avatar to make. Or
there are no good male anime
avatars that I can choose from.
So these kinds of reasons, I
think, is what this thesis is to
challenge.
So one of my auto ethnographic
experiences stick out to me. So
I was invited to a concert of a
French musician by a publicist,
I met at Sundance. And so once I
got there, I felt the excitement
of crowds of avatars waiting,
but around 40 minutes in there
was no show. After repeated
technical difficulties combined
with people getting frustrated,
as someone in our hearts named
Nico Avatar ran to the front of
the stage and started dancing in
front of everyone to the
laughter and encouragement of
some male users. Afterwards, I
asked about it and the guy said,
it was just I was just clicking
the emote button and I didn't
make this myself. Almost as a
disclaimer, the emote button is
so impersonal and detached. Yet
as a viewer, that situation
didn't really feel that way. Of
course, it's the automated girl
in a short skirt who placates
the crowd. In this Act, the
avatarization of anime girls
reflects stereotypes about Asian
femininity and bodily labor. The
digital avatar itself and what
it's coded in it produced an
effect, like the guy said he
only clicked a button. So I want
to think more about the animate
girl avatar as a material object
and as an assemblage of signs.
Avatarizing desire. Even if it
is not the user's own, it is a
symbol that reproduces cultural
hegemony. binding to the
settings and technical
structures of MMD based models
are tied to values that
reproduce tropes about Asian
bodies. This is known but not
interrogated, although it
affects social culture. So by
analyzing the data structure, I
was able to track trace them the
movement and history across
media platforms. The MMD model
is a 3d model that originated
from the fan culture surrounding
Hatsune Miku, who is a vocal
software virtual singer, an
anime figure who transcends
multiple media forms, using the
freeware MMD software, which
stands for Miku Miku dance fans
could animate because bodies
into different dance moves and
uploaded, released in 2008. The
software is one of the earliest
that allows complex joint
centers exist stands for
humanoid avatar bodies. For this
reason it's been used to make
music videos, crowdsource
choreography for concerts, user
generated pornography. And now
in part, VRChat avatars,
learning tutorials for how to
make VRChat avatar from MMD
model share more than just the
technical knowledge but also the
makers attitudes towards their
avatar and its imagery,
specifications of value
preferences and dampening,
elasticity stiffness etc,
especially desire to pour
control through technical
mastery of particular body
parts. Humor is also often used
to reinforce this. Post packs
are pre made gestures, the
enemies the avatars and orient
the possibilities for that
avatar's actions, which include
play and touch of body parts, or
the flowing movements of long
hair. Moreover, MMD base will
advertise rely on pre existing
media infrastructure such as
repositories of user made
models, such as on like mckone
solid, there are a lot of
freelance artists, hobbyists,
devoted fans who build up this
open and participatory culture
and it's really quite
incredible. So in many cases,
the act of building an avatar
from scratch contributes to the
feeling of ownership and an
identification with it by
culture works algorithmically.
And the stereotypical features
of these media representations
carry on to the space in
subversive ways. I've used a
shoujo school girl avatar once
to go through this process and
only in VRChat, I realized that
when moving around, people could
see up that skirt. In a way the
claim that the MMD is the most
convenient and easy guest avatar
is partly true here but there's
there's more to it.
So thinking beyond the anime
girl, a phrase used by English
speakers of VRC, let's consider
the concept of shōjo and be sure
to more broadly. So shōjo is a
term that means the Japanese
term that means girl or young
woman, and typically refers to
the audience of shōjo manga, so
adolescent girls who are the
drivers of East culture, the
imagery of the shōjo figure
across East Asian cultures and
consumer culture reify notions
of agency and femininity, the
pure virginal maiden who is
simultaneously sexually
empowered, like VRC space the
spectacle of mixed signs and
interpretations. The
transnational media scape of
shoujo are also complexly
intertwined. In Anne Alison's
study of Japanese toys she
articulates how the material
production of media are tied
with and global fantasies, as
Tomiko Yoda says, of girl
culture in Japan, objects are
immersed in a mediatic audience,
blurring the distinction between
the manufacturing process
product itself, and its
distribution and promotion.
According to Tomiko Yoda the
history of girls magazines
reflect a transformative point
between girl and woman becoming
a woman is a transformation with
no return with little residue.
It is a fundamental paradox of
girl culture, that this erasing
transformation is accompanied by
elaboration of the intricately
pleasurable practices of being a
girl becoming a girl. I think
back to my earlier anecdote
about the dancing Hatsune Miku
my effective relation towards
shōjo imagery. You know, we have
Sailor Moon here who is an
incredibly empowering figure
young girls identify with being
used in contexts. Outside of
that shōjo imagery, though, has
aesthetic continuities with be
shōjo, which translates to
beautiful girl, and shifts men
as primary consumers of its
artifacts, and is used as a
figure in adult dating games or
as an idol figures like Miku. So
children are not only objects of
affection. They are active
agents of stories which many
people identify with and
understanding the effect of
complexity toward the shadow.
Shōjo aesthetic depends on your
global position and experience
with media representations. the
proliferation of this ambiguous
imagery, transgressing public
and private spaces reproduces
damaging, phantasms in virtual
and mediatized worlds as shoujo
Hatsune Miku symbolizes a
fluidity of meanings attached to
media and the different material
forms and lives that can take.
So here we see a hologram of
Mika selling out concerts a man
in Japan also has married a
hologram of sneakers. So how can
you describe this phenomenon
happening because fan based
include otaku who are young
media savvy, hardcore fans of
anime manga video games, and
came out from the rapid
technological advancements in
the 80s. In Japan, moe is a term
that describes a euphoric
response to an intimacy with
these fantasy characters and the
representations of them. Moe is
an effect in response to fantasy
forms, and typically describe a
burning passion for these young
cute anime girls. Digital Media
scholars consider Hatsune Miku
fan practices as democratic
democratized a participatory
culture of web 2.0. Some
theorists consider otaku as more
open to other possibilities of
becoming a human In between man
and machine, a new God, that
transcendent relation to the
technological bodies, or a
harrowing interpretation of a
contemporary cyborg. But what
does it mean for a vision for
online participation or a vision
for post human subjectivity to
be shōjo, a mediatized girl from
Japan. I argue that the idea of
the anime girl being post racial
is a myth. shoujo is situated in
cultural representation of Asian
femininity and continue to hold
effective relationships with
young girls that I argue should
be the active agents of its
aesthetic mediatized or not,
especially as we are entering an
increasingly mediatized and
virtualized world, the
arbitration of desire needs to
be designed as defined as such.
Moreover, global nature of an
economy requires us to revisit
this aesthetic and its potential
implications across global
audiences. So another point of
discussion is the global export
of Asian femininity, and quite
literally, of woman themselves.
In the cool Japan campaign is
the culture pan campaign is part
of the Japanese foreign
ministry's brand strategy to
export its media and commercial
projects products abroad while
inviting tourism. Here you see
Kizuna AI, another figure like
Hudson, a Miku, well known as a
Virtual Youtuber reaching out,
saying come to Japan in front of
a natural landscape. This type
of imagery reinforce ideas of
Japan and Japanese woman as a
site for exploration. Here we
have the three ambassadors of
cute from 2009, reflecting the
tropes about Asian woman
propagated by the National
Japanese Government themselves
the school girl Lolita, the
Harajuku style girl.
Certainly all discourses related
to shōjo. These girls visit
various countries promoting
popular culture. So when we
think about techno Orientalism
and VRChat, it's critical to
consider the economic and social
history of mediatized girls
through the lens of advertising
and the export of these images.
technic Orientalism is not only
a question of West versus east,
which by the way is often used
synonymously with a single
country of Japan, rather
technical Orientalism is
question of is a question of
global imperialism in which
power is an emotion across
national ethnic and racial
lines. So a key insight coming
out from here is that we need
more feminist design of digital
avatars to reveal the racial and
gender power dynamics in virtual
world making. Social VR however,
does offer possibilities for
sincere expression, identity,
expression and play. There's
been many uses for
rehabilitative purposes for
addiction or treating mental
health. For instance, as
psychology research has shown,
anime girl avatars are also used
by femme trans femme identified
folks who might be experimenting
with gender expression. There's
a and Club Zodiac on the right
here it's another instance Club
Zodiac is a pole dancing
community that uses full body
tracking to perform in front of
VRC audiences. While the anime
style aesthetic is used. The
modifications make made Express
user agency in the adjustments
to body types their skin tones
were over the use of full body
tracking to dance strengthens
the continuities between the
actions of the Avatar and that
of the user. Unlike the emote
button we discussed earlier.
Social VR offers possibilities
for bridging geographical
barriers for shared experience.
Here's a still from the
immersive theater performance
scarecrow VRChat. When I asked
which from a production crew in
Korea, when I asked the
interlocutor of mine, how much
of this audience here is from a
film festival and from the
VRChat community. And they said
about how have we all shared
this moment through key arts
creative performance. So I now
move into my more creative work.
As during kind of writes,
creativity is work practice
method, a site of theory making
and political intervention. So
here we have the shoujo ghost.
And the shoujo goes to me as a
character concept that's still
in progress. But as my talk has
covered, the materiality of
digital avatars hold agency
separately from that of the
user, the shoujo ghost is an
expression of this agency in the
form grounded in memory, the the
story of the Avatar is on me
girl, the shoujo ghost creates a
memory of this phenomenon in
social VR in a way that informs
future world making from the
point of view of animist
mythologies. My concept of the
shōjo ghost is largely inspired
by the legend of Haesindang, who
is a virgin ghost spirit and sea
spirit in a fishing village in
[...] Korea. As the legend goes,
has she done is a young maiden
whose fiance left her on a rock
while he was going to fish she
got washed over the shore and
passed away. Her virgin spirit
not having fulfilled her womanly
purpose raged over the village,
and to appease her spirit, the
villagers would erect phallic
statues around her shrine. The
shōjo post is a play on the
virgin ghost but also re
strategy of this idea. She is
the spirit of the avatarized
anime girl in VRChat long
divorced from their origin. The
shōjo ghost yearns for technical
intimacy and associated only by
rituals of heteronormative
sexuality and VRChat does her
form as ghost actually is her
most pronounced expression of
agency within this condition and
must be exercised in order to
reimagine virtual worlds. So to
give some more clarity here, I
introduced the idea of cyber
demonic performance. So cyber
demonic performance is really
centered on the idea of
expanding notions of virtual
world making through practices
that are rooted in embodying and
enacting memory centering voices
in the margins. shamanism is
incredibly broad and contested
term and is practiced across
culture with regional
differences by cyber shamanic
performance, I'm referring
primarily to shamanic practice
in Korea and its
interrelationships to media
technologies. sekret corresponds
with its specific modern
history. shamans or mudang are
predominantly women who are
conceived of as carriers of
stories of trauma through
Korea's modern history. As
healers, priests performance and
profits. shamans revived gaps
and emissions and cultural
memory through practices of
remembrance. In the Buryat
context in Mongolia Manduhai
Buyandelger theorizes shamanic
performances as enacted memories
realized in multiple media such
as gesture, language, food,
music and material objects.
So shamanism and Korea has ties
to media technologies. Then this
documentary recreation of the
life of the Korean with Kim
Keum-hwa. The young girl is
collecting scrap metal from our
village to sponsor the [...] for
her initiation ritual to become
a shaman. We see here the self
reflexive inclusion of the film
crew and placing the camera into
the bag as one of the tools
signifying this union between
technologies of virtuality and
gestures of goodwill towards
towards their use. And CYSHA is
a contemporary work by Hyung-Gi
Kim, where that allows you to is
an exploration this artist uses
cyber-shamanic performance to
explore diasporic identity. The
ultimate work of shamans in
reconstituting the past is not
history, but memory, knowledge
of the past that is
emotionalized embodied and
attached to an individual. This
brings us back to a place of
care. Currently a work in
progress. There are a lot of
values that we can draw from
cyber-shamanic performance, one
of them being an emphasis on
healing, a place of care brings
you into the massage room. It's
a place to consider the lives
lost to senseless gun violence.
And it's also a place to
consider the systemic dynamics
of police violence and
transnational histories of Asian
woman body labor. As Asian
massage workers, sex workers and
survivors of human trafficking
continue to be impacted by anti
migration, policing and the
criminalization of their
livelihoods. A place of care
invites us to consider the
implications of damaging
cultural phantasms about Asian
femininity, virtually, but also
three blocks down to at our
local Asian massage business. In
this work, I draw from popular
storytelling practices, pairing
with 360 video of [...], which
is a shamanic dance to resolve
sorrow, and transform the pain
into reality of pain of reality
into beauty, and concludes with
all participants joining
together collectively near an
ocean shore landscape.
So, as a brief conclusion,
today, I examined the cultural
production of the anime girl
avatar in VRChat to understand
sociotechnical relations towards
virtual world making. I
deconstructed cultural biases
and social VR explored the
potential of this as a site for
performing identity, and
ultimately argued that being
autonomy is not a post racial
category, but one built from a
very specific and situated
cultural history. And so in
terms of future work, I'll be
doing a Fulbright Fellowship in
South Korea and my research
project is to investigate how
historical archives, folk
storytelling, and cultural
memory could be a more central
part to virtual world making.
I'm curious about how virtual
technologies can be used for
creative educational curricula,
and how digital performances can
be a research method or a mode
of inquiry. So thank you so much
for listening to my
presentation. And I'll stop
sharing the screen now.
Vivek Bald: Right, thanks so
much, Andrea. We're open for
questions. William,
William Uricchio: Thanks. Thanks
a lot. Andrea. It's really
provocative and big and always
hearing about your work always
makes my mind like explode a
little bit. And I'm afraid I
have kind of a question that
reveals more about my ignorance
than than anything else. So
Hatsune Miku, as you've rightly
said, gets usually emblazoned
with words like democratization,
web 2.0. This is a contributory
fan based. I don't know the
empirical work behind it in
terms of gender divide, like who
makes it and who doesn't? Is
that exclusively male fantasy?
Or are women involved with that?
But my question actually
connects with with your point
about the shaman and your this
notion of memory versus history.
And I get the critique if Miku
has kind of history if it's out
there. But it strikes me that
it's is emotionalized. It is
embodied it is attached to
individuals to contribute to it.
That contributory dimension
complicates that character, in
my mind anyway. So for example,
the work on querying of Miku.
Right for a particular
community, that is a very
personal kind of assertion. It's
an embodied assertion, they've
taken the time to work on the on
the, on the drawing themselves.
And I'm just wondering how that
works like this, this divide
between history and memory is an
intriguing one. It's the
shamanic dimension that you that
you mentioned at the end,
doesn't make who slide in and
out of that, between being out
there and being part of us who
produce it, those those who
produce it? Because it is
emotional investment, it is an
embodied act. Yeah, that I guess
that's my question that I'm
struck by that, for me. And this
is ignorance as much as anything
that kind of ambivalence of that
of, of that figure.
Yeah,
that's my question.
Andrea Kim: Yeah, I think this
is partly where my situated
approach comes in. Because
there's a lot I can read about
Hatsune Miku being like a symbol
for this or a symbol for that.
But I think at the end of the
day, like the approach that I've
chosen, and like thinking about
the specific, like, imageries,
that Hatsune Miku, or, like, the
way that that avatar was used
in, like, the anecdote that I
shared, I think, is the center
point of this discussion about
what she could represent as a
virtual virtual idol. And so I
would have to look into like,
exactly the distribution of the
gender distribution for who is
her fan base, but, um, from the
readings that I've had, it is
largely driven by like the otaku
male fan base. And I think that,
yeah,
William Uricchio: but it's less
the fan base, because I know
there are definitely a lot of
fans, it's more of the creative
base. It's the it's the place
that she comes from, it's the
hands that generate her figure.
And it's the hands that
manipulate that figure in fair
enough to take an instance. But
there is like, there is some,
let's say, I haven't read much
about it, but I have read is on
the querying of the character,
which is a, you know, a really
interesting, again, not just
fans, but creators. So it's that
that polyphonic notion of
creativity, That, to me, helps
this character straddle the the
history memory thing is a nice
way to talk about it, that this
is embodied memory for some
people, those who have
contributed to making it worse
for others. Yeah, it's just it's
just a thing to look at. Like we
look at history, we're
outsiders, and we look at this
distant artifact, but Okay,
that's the fair, fair answer.
Vivek Bald: Questions.
Well, I have another historical
question. And that is just the,
the what are the origins? And
again, and what are the origins
of the original two dimensional
form of the enemy girl? And you
know what, I guess I'm thinking
about Stuart Hall's concept of
the historical conjuncture,
right? And what you know, what
were the various kind of
historical forces at play in the
creation of that particular
figure? And, you know, how does
that how does that differ from
the present moment or the moment
where, where the enemy girl form
becomes the I'm animated into
three dimensions in VR worlds.
And so I'm just curious about
the relationship between the
origins of, of the figure in two
dimensions, and, and the kind of
moment that you're looking at in
your work.
Andrea Kim: Right. So I, in
terms of tracing origins of, I
guess the shoujo aesthetic, I
read about kind of girl
magazines in Japan and Tomiko
Yoda's work discussed how in
girl, so I guess, like, I was
trying to I was trying to bring
in these themes from girls
magazines, in the history of
kind of, like, media for, for,
for young girls, to to express,
like attention, like a thematic
tension, like for instance,
becoming woman is transformative
with no return and little
residue. Yet it's an it's a
fundamental paradox of girl
culture. That erases this
transformation. Yeah, so I guess
I'm, I think looking at the
history of shoujo will will say
that it is the audience of it is
actually towards shoujo young
girls themselves and in the form
of girl magazines. Oh,
Fox Harrell: I have a question.
I don't know if they're, I can't
see if their hands to
Vivek Bald: Paul had his hand
up. Okay. So why don't we go
Paul in in Fox.
Paul Roquet: Okay, my hands
blending in with the wall.
Thanks, Andrea, that was great
to see sort of how you brought
all these things that we've been
talking about sort of together,
it was really nice to, to, and I
really appreciated how you
brought in the context of
massage and care. And that's
what I wanted to ask more about.
It's always been striking.
Hearing men talk about why
they're using anime girl avatars
in VR, in that it's often seems
to have a aspect of care or
relaxation, or they say it's
very easy to have people talk to
you because you look a certain
way. Or there's a kind of
soothing quality, not
confrontational quality, which,
of course, as you describe is
completely over determined and
racialized, and, and has all
that context around it. But at
the same time, it's often
precisely along these lines of
care or effect of flavor, or
certain kind of emotional
association with the form that
comes through. So I was
wondering if you could maybe
elaborate a little bit on this
larger context you're drawing
out of if the, the anime girl
avatar is actually a tool of
care in some context, or could
actually play a role on the same
kind of affective restorative
level. But then you're also
trying out this other context
with the performance of the the
space of massage and also the
kind of shamanic ritual space,
as well. As any of you could
kind of, yeah, where where the
the avatar fits into this
question of care, and care work.
Andrea Kim: Yeah, thank you, I
think, um, yeah. In terms of
like, you know, the emotional
aspects, and, and feelings of
care towards these toward like,
my way and towards autonomy
girls, I think that's totally,
you know, it's certainly an
expression of care. So, yes, I
would completely agree with
that. But I think a question
comes like, towards, you know,
how, what happens when these
types of visions for care, you
know, in VRChat through the
anime girl, it doesn't feel
accessible to other people who
might have like, reactions
against that aesthetic. So I
think like, My project is really
speaking towards the need, you
know, looking at these
phenomenons in embodiment,
embodying different anime
characters. Like I mentioned,
you know, the possibilities for
gender play using these anime
characters or, you know, other
instantiations of user agency
and empowerment. But um, yeah,
so but I guess like my project
is, is searching for kind of
alternative visions as well too,
that are like inspired, I guess
by you know, these
instantiations of virtual
personhood, which are instead
like they are certainly virtual
virtual personhood. But are, you
know, made in spaces of
exclusions?
Vivek Bald: Fox?
Fox Harrell: Sure. So I want to
just ask Andrea just so we could
explore a little bit more about
this. The idea that say that the
anime girl character could can
be There's a reappropriated by
communities for empowering or
even transgressive kind of
purposes versus it seems like a
lot of what you're arguing about
is that there is still a kind of
resonant violence that is often
done, especially for a lot of
Asian female users within the
space. And what it makes me
think of, you know, so there was
a paper in a MIT Press book
written by Simon Penny, the
robotics artist and professor,
where he describes one
exhibition that he mentions as
unfortunate and Ill conceived.
And so the way he describes it,
and I'll say there's a mistake
in the way he describes it, I
mentioned in a second, but he
describes it as a work Kan Xuan
by Alexander Brandt. And it's
interactive work in which there
is an Asian woman who is nude
lying face up projected onto a
life size crumpled crop cloth on
the stone floor in a dark
corner. And the only thing users
can do in this interactive
exhibition is to stomp on this
projection. And it's interactive
in the sense that she will then
recoil and pain and so forth,
and eventually even fade away.
So, you know, he critiques that
as being a work that's created
by a white male, and something
that is, you know, its work that
is seen as oppressive, and based
in colonial fantasies, and much
more. Actually, there was a
mistake in his analysis. Kan
Xuan was the artist who was an
Asian female artist, and
Alexander Brandt was the curator
or gallery owner. And so there
was a misreading that was there.
But I think it's telling because
still the resonance, like
regardless of the fact that
there was a kind of
reappropriation of her own image
within the work, it was still
read in this kind of in this
kind of oppressive way. And it
seems to be related to what
you're saying that if people
just want to take up a image
that has some kind of violent
resonance, or connects to those
histories, even if for them, it
feels somehow kind of redemptive
or empowering in the world. It
might not be because somebody
else going to the gallery
wouldn't feel what the artists
felt when she created that work.
And it seems to me that's where
they're kind of that kind of
insights of Manduhai, and and
your work are important that
it's not enough just to take up
the Avatar and then within your
sub community to use that as
some kind of empowerment work.
The somatic practice seems like
it's doing the additional work
thinking through what really has
to happen in order for it to be
transformative, in a broader
sense for other visitors in the
space. And, and not just to kind
of an internal one. And so
that's in some sense, your
commentary, but I also wonder if
that resonates with how you are
seeing the shamanic work is sort
of going beyond just communities
reappropriating imagery, but
trying to make sure that it
actually does the work that they
intend to more broadly.
Andrea Kim: Right, I think thank
you so much for that comment,
Fox. I think, um, yeah, I think
my work once is responding to
the fact of exclusions in
virtual personhood. And it's,
it's, to me, I think that alone
is an argument against why it is
a form of virtual personhood.
And we have to consider kind of
like the,
Vivek Bald: you know,
Andrea Kim: more popularized, I
guess, more truly democratized
form of virtual personhood. I
argue looks would look
different. And so yeah, and and
with the shamanic practices
being rooted in giving voice to
more like marginalized
experiences, or, you know, being
a carrier of popular
acknowledges and stories, I
think, yeah, that resonates.
Vivek Bald: There's one more
question before we move on in in
the chat. That is from Diane
Kim, congratulations on the
Fulbright. Andrea, I would love
to learn more about how you want
to carry out the project in
Korea. What are some topics
you're excited to explore?
Andrea Kim: Yeah so I I've been
really loving kind of digital
media performance using social
VR. So I'd be curious to think
more about how social VR can be
used And fourthly yet for
theater or in you know, and I
would love at a part of my work
in full right involves
ethnographic work in different
like mask dance, mask, dance,
traditions. And so I think it
could be interesting to think
about how like, ritual objects
are built or like artistic
objects are built that have a
more like ritualistic history,
and think about how that
relationship to materials can be
used in virtual reality context
as well. So coming up with new
design principles that are more
rooted in like, like performance
practices, practices like mask
dances, and how like the the
costumes or objects are
prepared.
Vivek Bald: Thank you so much,
Andrea. And let's have another
round of applause. Wonderful
work.